[Music]
welcome back to SEO foundations in this
video we're going to cover on-page
optimization there are hundreds of
signals that are used by the search
engines to determine the best search
results for any given query generally
speaking these signals can be
categorized into two broad categories
relevancy and popularity in this lesson
we will be discussing on-page signals or
signals related to relevancy these
signals tell users and search engines
what a given website is about
describe the two broad categories of
ranking signals recite best practices
for on-page signals such as title tags
header tags URLs alt text and others
list and describe on-page SEO tactics
that you should avoid describe our
natural language processing aims to
understand the meaning behind text
search engine optimization is very very
complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it's very easy and best to just break it
into general concepts you already have
some understanding of so when I look at
the hundreds of cuds of signals that go
into SEO I break all them up into either
relevancy and/or because sometimes it's
both popularity so relevancy popularity
out of all these signals they fit into
one of these two things throughout the
rest of this chapter in this course
we're going to break all the signals we
have into these two areas so that you
can rely on what you already know about
the concept of relevancy and the concept
of popularity to have some kind of
anchor point for these new brand these
new ideas in this section we're going to
talk about the on-page factors and I'll
tell you right up front these are going
to come your favorite these are the ones
that you have the most impact on and
that you can make a small tweak and have
a gigantic impact on the amount of
organic traffic that you send start with
one of my favorites title tags title
tags are the single most important
on-page metric that we have access to
this is text that we get to express that
we get to write that shows the intent
and the purpose of that page on the
Internet this is really really important
because search engines use this this
text that we get to provide in their
search results directly so we get to
write what becomes the headline of the
search result itself this in addition to
the Meta Description as we'll cover next
are the two factors that we have a whole
lot of control over that influence both
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our brand next up we have
meta descriptions now meta descriptions
are a little bit confusing because it is
text that we get to provide to search
engines but more often than not they
override what we provide and try to
choose something that is better in their
opinion now I go both ways with this
sometimes it really is better most the
time though in my opinion it's not but
the important thing here is that we get
to provide what would normally we'd have
to pay for with AD copy we get to
provide it for free customize it to
however we want to type to entice clicks
and the
search engines are happy to promote that
and show that in the search results
all right now we're getting into the
good nerdy stuff the header tags so this
was something that's built into HTML
when the web was first created the idea
here is that you're establishing a
hierarchy so you start with one h1
saying what the main purpose of the
pages and you start to break it into
subcategories so you'll have multiple
h2s below that multiple h3 is between
all of that now each one's used to be a
very important in primary SEO metric
that we got to use but because it got
abused it now has less of an importance
than you used to so it shows what
information is less or more important
than other information on the page but
it is no longer the strongest indicator
of what is the most important page on it
and right now that's still title tags
next up we have URLs Uniform Resource
locators now these are the addresses of
web documents online just like give a
street address for your house on the
internet we have URLs for any given
document anywhere it can be PDFs it
could be images it could be texting via
your home page all these have URLs these
are extremely important for SEO for a
variety of reasons the most important
though is your keyword usage you want to
make sure that the words that you're
trying to rank for are included in your
URLs the second part of this ties in
directly the first is you want to keep
these short so it's not okay to just put
a whole lot of words you want to write
for in your L you need to remember that
humans are the people are the things
that use the internet they share URLs
they try to say them over the phone to
do all these different things where it
becomes extremely important to keep
these short and succinct so that people
can easily share them and contact them
in their browser without any issues now
that we've talked about the importance
of URLs let's talk about URL structure
dive in a little bit here we'll start
with domain names so you probably heard
of this concept before in the example
with the URL I have here example.com
would be the domain name so this is the
first thing that people see with your
online businesses what's giving all your
advertisements I mean all your marketing
efforts it's this name right here I like
to think of it in terms of an offline
world so if you walk around buildings
typically look like something so a
barber shop almost always looks like a
barber shop a fast-food restaurant
almost always looks like a fast-food
restaurant that same idea is going to
apply to domain names if you're a very
spammy looking domain name or one that's
hard to spell or one that's confusing
people are going to make an initial
impression off of that so make sure that
you have something there that it's going
to make a great first impression be
something that's easy to spell that one
new tech like tech craziness that we
live in people do a terrible job of that
but something that's easy to spell and
something easy to pronounce and it easy
to share so how is this important SEO
well keywords or wide support net CEO
this it comes up all the time it's
important to have keywords in your
domain name as long as you're not taking
it too far now this is one of the things
I go back and forth with people all the
time how do you know if you've gone too
far I don't know I mean if it looks like
you bought the domain name simply
because it has the keywords in it that
you needed then you've probably gone too
far but is that the best way of
measuring it can I take out my
calculator and actually calculate that
now you're just going to have to use
your gut you have to look at it from
making it from a human perspective so to
not go overboard keep it as short as
possible make sure it's something that
you can easily share something you'll be
able to put on your business cards and
be proud of not something that you
bought because you're doing this purely
for SEO reasons you think you're going
to succeed okay so that is the domain
name now what about everything after
that so in this case it would be this
blog post that I wrote
well that is called a sub directories
and you can actually have in theory
unlimited sub directories but from an
SEO perspective you do not want to do
that and for all the reasons we talked
about before if you have lots of sub
directories it's going to be confusing
its me hard to share it's going to cause
lots of problems in older browsers so
your best practice here is to keep as
few sub directories as possible this
will be good for both robots and for
human beings with the sub directories as
well as the files that come after them
you want to make sure you include your
keywords so again this is one of those
weird things where there's not a
quantified metric for it but don't put
the keywords in there too many times but
put them in there just as many times as
you think is absolutely necessary so
generally this is once or maybe twice if
it's already a been domain name okay
that's all the information I have right
now on URLs feel free to google this
subject if you if you want to know more
about it because trust me there's a
whole lot of technical knowledge that
goes in this but if you're at this point
you already understand all the most
important parts of it as you like we
realize computers cannot see images the
same way that humans can they do not
have eyes and they do not have the
complex brains that we use to get
meaning out of pictures out of pixels so
because of that we've had to come up
with some other way of expressing the
meaning behind images luckily the
creators of the internet were
forward-thinking and they provided us
with a factor called image alt text alt
text is the
the alternative text that is shown when
image can't load this is done on purpose
so that people who are blind are able to
extract meaning from something when they
can't see it
this works out really well for search
engines because well they're effectively
brought effectively blind and so that
they can also use that information put
into the image alt text to understand
the meaning behind images internal links
so we have an entire section on links
but what I want to cover at this point
is just internal links an internal link
is a link that points from your website
back to a different section of your own
website it's not pointing elsewhere it's
not coming from elsewhere
it's from your website back to your own
website this is important from a
relevant irrelevant C perspective you'll
see internal links in your main
navigation when you'll have one that
likely says home one that might say
contact us or one this is about what
you're showing two search engines and
two humans is that this section that if
you click on this link will be about our
company or this will be a place where
you can find contact information for us
these links are not votes like external
links but they are relevancy metrics
that are extremely helpful when a search
engine crawls and processes your website
it doesn't simply look for the instances
of keywords it's a lot more complex than
that it's using a technology called MLP
natural language processing what is
trying to do is it's using algorithms to
try to understand the meaning of text
the same way humans do when they listen
to other people talk or read read text
instead of just looking for specific
phrases or like the order of words it
tries to extract what's behind that what
is what is trying to be expressed here
emotion feeling food anything so when a
search engine goes to your website it
may see key words but it's looking for
context to them you may say just soccer
but just having the word soccer on your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for soccer what you need to
do and what is more common actually
happens naturally is that you'll happen
to use words like goal and World Cup and
referee Google and the other search
engines are going to take these into
account and understand what that you
rank for soccer or the irrelevant for
that kind of keyword by the usage of
other synonyms and other common words
that are used within the context of a
bigger broader idea the next on-site
signal that we have is sitemaps now
there's two kinds of sitemaps there's
the kind that are for humans and there's
a kind of that are for robots or
crawlers or spiders the limiter for
humans are called HTML sitemaps and
you've probably seen these before
they're generally in the footer of
website click through it and it shows
you the major sections of a website and
usually provide some search
functionality those help you understand
as a human what the hierarchy of a
website is how does everything fit
together and how do I get to the to
something I'm looking for as quickly as
possible those are called HTML sitemaps
and like I said they're generally for
humans there's also something that
exists on the back end called an XML
sitemap now this is something you can
actually look at but it's formatted for
computers so it's not going to be easy
to read an XML sitemap uses a format
called XML as you can probably imagine
to show the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs on your website so
that search engines can understand that
and figure out how everything is
interconnected so this point we've
covered a lot of things that are
important and things that you should be
doing and optimizing now let's go the
different direction and cover things
that you should not be doing so these
are lists of the most common mistakes
that I see that should not be done for a
well optimized page the first one is
keyword stuffing so back in the day it
used to be helpful on again this is in
the past it's not true anymore it used
to be helpful to put lots of instances
of the keyword that you were trying to
rank for on the page search engines and
humans for that matter are a lot smarter
about this now than they used to be
keyword stuffing does not work
you're not going to rank better for any
given phrase by including 100 100 times
on the page so this is something that
doesn't work you should not do anymore
the next one is hidden text
unfortunately I still see this one all
over the web this is when you write
content that is solely for search
engines it's not for people and you'll
put it say white text on a white
background so a search engine can see
this because their crawler they're a
machine but humans cannot because they
cannot see the difference because
there's no contrast now that also used
to work back in the day but it does not
and that is not a useful thing to invest
your time in today
search engines it can tell when it's
white text on white background it's
actually very easy to tell from from a
computer science point of view there's
other ways of trying to hide things but
when you hide text modern search engines
are most certainly smart enough to be
able to figure that out probably better
than humans to be to be honest so don't
bother trying to hide text just for
search engines they're going to figure
it out and still work against you next
one is repetitive anchor text so we've
all read these articles where you get to
a page
and it just doesn't feel like it was
written for people you're reading a
sentence and it's redundant it's got
lots of links in it that really don't
need to be links it's just confuses the
way the flow of the information on the
page because you put links when they're
really they're not necessary this also
used to be a tactic that used to work
but is no longer helpful search engines
the natural language processing
algorithms the use have advanced
significantly so they can tell when
something is not readable when something
is probably intended for machines and
not for people so do not waste your time
on redundant links and trying to try to
sculpt your PageRank or your your link
equity or the value of your links anyway
like that because just today's world it
does not work last thing that we have on
here is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to search engines and
something entirely different to humans
now this is also like everything else
almost something that used to work but
as I've mentioned before search engines
have their algorithms have gotten much
smarter and much more clever and they
can almost always figure out the
difference between when you're doing
this if you're showing one thing to
search engine something else to humans
with if with only a few exceptions that
I know of it which are in the process of
going out there's no reason to do this
so it is not something that worth
investing your time in now we've covered
all the most important on-page
optimization factors let's take a look
at what the theoretical perfectly
optimized page would look like on the
Internet now there's a big asterisk here
in that well no page would be perfectly
optimized because the Internet's dynamic
and fluid and things change all the time
but if there was one it would look very
eerily similar to what we're about to
talk about let's start with the basics
you need to have a title tag the title
tag needs to have optimized keywords in
it preferably closer to the beginning of
it and it needs to be clear and enticing
for users to click remember this is what
we're going to actually see in search
results for most the time for your
surgery before the search result itself
is you're going to have this text here
so a clear and optimized title tag the
next thing is an enticing meta
description
now remember meta descriptions not used
for ranking purposes but they are
tremendously important for click
throughs so this is the this is your
chance to write copy this can entice
people to click through your result
rather than the other one third remai on
the search result page after that we
have a short optimized URL so the
important here thing here is that needs
to be short so it's easily shareable
it's easy to understand from a search
engine perspective but it also needs to
contain the keywords that you're trying
to rank for so keep it there keep it in
plain equal English use the phrases
people are actually using to get to your
site but keep it as concise as humanly
possible now let's talk about the page
itself what does this actually look like
how are things structured well the first
thing you want to do is you want to make
sure that is structured in the same way
that people expect to see websites
meaning there is a title at the top if
it's appropriate there's some kind of
navigational elements around the site
there are pictures to make this worthy
of me to spend the five minutes of my
internet time grazing looking at your
content you need to have text that is
well written and this all is very hard
to quantify but it's things that you're
going to just take a look at and work
with your team for things that are
interesting there's an attitude with the
page that has some kind of opinion it's
expressing information it's giving me
the answer to whatever question I may
have you make sure this content at the
end of day is written for humans there's
something that I would share with my
best friend because I think this is the
single best source on the internet for
whatever my information need is at that
moment after that it needs to be bought
accessible so I actually see this
problem all the time with some of the
major news publications the world will
have a really outstanding article or
they'll have a really beautiful photo
gallery but they've done it in a way
where the search engines can't see it
which means that on the internet it's
almost useless which is which is a shame
it's sad when this happens what you need
to do is you need to make sure that you
have the world's best content which is
hard enough but you also have to make it
accessible to search engines so this is
certainly very doable just to avoid
technologies like flash and say
Silverlight and use more of these open
standards like html5 that will get you
all the way there the next one is social
it needs to be social it needs to be
shareable so I had mentioned the my what
I'm trying to create content that the
bar that I tried to rise to is that is
shareable for my best friend well you
need to facilitate that sharing you need
to have some kind of way for them to
actually share it so this could be as
simple as adding the social sharing
buttons or it could be something as easy
as enticing them and giving them a call
to action at the end of the article to
share it with their friends or share
with people who are important to them
sharing on the Internet is extremely
important not just for ethical reasons
but for marketing reasons for
bottom-line reasons so make sure that
your
I am the last one and it is certainly
not the least important one is
multi-device ready so I don't care if
you use adaptive design I don't care if
you use responsive design just make sure
that this content you spend so much time
crafting is going to work and it's going
to be consumable easily on my tablet and
on my phone and on my gigantic TV and
all these other devices so that when it
comes time when you finally earned that
person coming to your website to consume
your really wonderful content that
they're able to see it on whatever
device it may be holding so this is a
general overview of what a perfectly
optimized website would look like now
remember this this is going to shift
depending on context but make sure if
you cover to cover all of these bases so
that the signals that we've all talked
about makes sense and you have a real
lasting impact with this
the two broad categories of ranking
signals are popularity and relevancy of
the on-page factors title tags are the
most important individual field header
tags are important but less so than they
were in the past URL is important and
should be semantic alt text is important
for search engine as well as for blind
humans avoid keyword stuffing and link
sculpting you should always avoid
keyword stuffing hidden text repetitive
anchor text and cloaking natural
language processing is a technology that
aims to understand the intent and
semantic structure behind text written
by humans hey once you become an expert
in digital marketing then subscribe to
the simply learned channel and click
here to watch more such videos turn up
and get certified in digital marketing
click here